[Music]
new video was just released of the
golfer in jail after he failed his field
sobriety test about two hours had passed
but it's clear Tiger was still heavily
impaired watch look during mixing as an
attendant I'll tell you stop
that's Tiger disoriented and attempting
to take his first of two breathalyzer
tests early Monday morning at the Palm
Beach County Jail hello out blow out
I'm suck it blow out okay hey breath in
in the 12 minute video
Tiger slurs his speech and seems to
struggle to keep his eyes open while
standing and sitting look come back here
and you're gonna sit in the chair cops
charged tiger with DUI after they found
him asleep behind the wheel of his black
Mercedes about ten miles from his home
in Jupiter Florida do you remember being
asleep in the car you don't after
failing several sobriety tests the 41
year old golfer was taken into custody
certainly please state your full name
Tom
Tiger was cooperative and at one point
even cracked a joke your hair and eye
color will sit for Allen
well
then before doing a second breathalyzer
test Tiger became confused by the
handcuffs bracelets Tiger registered a
point zero zero on both tests in a
statement Tiger blamed a bad reaction to
prescription medication for the incident
have you taken any illegal drugs okay
have you taken any medication